[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
new york's governor andrew cuomo now
under criminal investigation for sexual
harassment allegations two more
prosecutors announced they're also
requesting evidence and contentious
cross-examination of robert durst expert
witness do you really want me because
you're a bully well real estate airs
defense as prosecutors rest their case
plus herring police body cam video
release of the surfside condo collapse
the chaos confusion and fear in those
first moments after the disaster i don't
even know how i made it out
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer co-host terry austin
is off we begin with a criminal
investigation into new york governor
andrew cuomo following the release of a
report that found he sexually harassed
multiple women law and crimes andrew
levy is here with the latest fallout
from new york's governor
brian diaz in three new york counties
albany manhattan and westchester have
all requested investigative materials
from the new york attorney general's
office and albany's d.a says that any
victim of crime is welcome to contact
his office
i think he should resign
the president of the united states
calling on governor cuomo to resign
following the release of that damning
report on sexual harassment governor
cuomo was defiant when responding to the
findings
trial by newspaper
or biased reviews
are not the way to find the facts in
this matter
i welcome the opportunity for a full and
fair review before a judge and a jury
independent investigators spoke with 11
women one a state trooper on governor
cuomo's security detail the report
includes photos of female employees with
governor cuomo in which they said he
touched them inappropriately and made
them uncomfortable
executive assistant one told
investigators the governor grabbed her
rear end when asking her to take a
selfie the report said the governor
denied touching her backside but albany
county's district attorney sees enough
merit in the report's findings to launch
a criminal investigation david soros
spoke to nbc nightly news
the allegations early on certainly led
myself and other prosecutors with
concurrent jurisdiction to uh to believe
that criminal activity in fact had taken
place but we will conduct our own
independent investigation it will be
done expeditiously
and we will arrive at those conclusions
soros said a formal complaint against
the governor is needed and his office
has made overtures to some accusers
new york state assembly has opened an
impeachment inquiry that whole process
could move pretty quickly with a trial
in the state senate possible in late
september early october
still though the governor has indicated
he will not be resigning
brian thanks angenet joining us today is
state attorney for palm beach county
florida dave ehrenberg dave just for a
moment i'm going to make you the albany
d.a i have that power here at law and
crime uh walk us through building a case
off of an attorney general's
investigation
yeah it's great to be back with you
brian the first step is to check out the
lengthy report from the attorney general
and go through it to look at crimes now
remember a lot of the stuff in there
would be a civil matter not a criminal
matter so you look at what would involve
the touching and instead of the words if
it's just the words that made people
feel like there was a hostile work
environment or sexual harassment that
would be in the civil context the
administrative context as well but not a
criminal matter now criminal matter
would be the touching so there are at
least three of the victims that
apparently alleged improper touching
under new york law the statute is
forcible touching and to come under that
statute which is a grade or a grade a
misdemeanor class a misdemeanor
punishment up to 364 days in jail you
would need to be touching an intimate
area so when the trooper said that cuomo
rubbed her stomach down to her hip is
that an intimate area that's the kind of
thing you need to follow up on so you
want to contact those three victims to
see if it matches the elements of the
statute forcible touching and you want
to check out their corroboration and you
want to make sure it all falls within
the two-year statute of limitations
absolutely and jeanette isn't governor
cuomo getting a lot of pressure to step
down from other governors
yeah he really is brian there are four
governors in the northeast including the
governors of new jersey and connecticut
who have jointly called on governor
cuomo to resign he's indicated he's not
going to do that
it is interesting though the governors
in new jersey and connecticut both
worked very closely with governor cuomo
during the coronavirus pandemic at the
very beginning so
they are really pushing on him to step
down
all right we'll continue to follow this
the fallout or at least appears to fall
out of governor cuomo who doesn't seem
to be stepping down anytime soon we'll
bring you more information as this
continues turning now to more top legal
news three of the former police officers
charged in george floyd's case want
their federal trial separated from derek
shovin
attorneys for j alexander king and two
tao say their clients would be unfairly
prejudiced if they went to trial
alongside chauvin attorneys for thomas
lane filed a motion asking to join the
request
tao's attorney also wants him to be
tried on his own all forex cops are
accused of violating floyd's civil
rights they're due in court next month
for their federal arraignment
dave talk to us about the reasons for
severance do they make sense and are you
surprised that the three officers aren't
blaming each other especially to tao
they definitely make sense for the
defense now for the prosecution my side
of the aisle we would want them all to
be tried together it's more efficient
it's easier to tell the story when
they're all in the courtroom at the same
time as opposed to have to just put them
all in silos and only tell part of the
story to the jury but for defendants it
definitely helps them because first they
don't want to be tarred with chauvin
chauvin is a national pariah why would
you ever want to as they say in the
world of pro wrestling get the rub from
that guy you know you don't want to be
associated with that guy and even though
you didn't necessarily do the same thing
and if your tau you didn't even have
your knee on george floyd's neck you
were the lookout
even though it's all caught on video but
you don't want to be put on the same
trial in the same courtroom as the guy
who has already been convicted of a very
serious felony who has become a national
pariah and so that's why it makes every
sense in the world for them to separate
their case from shogun yeah i would
agree as well i would expect even to tao
to separate again from from lane and uh
the other officer as well but we'll give
you updates on that as that progresses
thank you dave ehrenberg still ahead of
law and crime daily will robert durst
take the stand the defense's case in the
trial of the real estate heir accused of
murder and later newly released body cam
video from the surfside condo collapse
the rescue efforts of first responders
and heartbreaking
[Music]
moments welcome back it's now robert
durst and his defense's turn to present
evidence in the murder trial of the real
estate air
robert durst insists he's innocent of
any murder and says he didn't kill his
best friend susan berman in december
2000 nor his first wife kathy in 1982.
prosecutors rested their case against
durst and the defense began by calling
memory expert dr elizabeth loftus she's
testified on behalf of the defense in
high profile cases such as harvey
weinstein and ted bundy
false memories can be caused by external
suggestion
if there is
some source outside the individual
person who
mentions something that is misleading or
erroneous in some way
in a conversation that can
lead a person to have a false memory
people get false memories when they're
interrogated and suggestive or leading
ways or if they're exposed to
a biased
media coverage that
insinuates things that may not be true
these are opportunities
for new information to
enter a witness's
awareness
and lead them to
remember something that is false
the doctor is known for her book titled
witness for the defense things got
heated on cross-examination when
prosecutor john lewin asked about the
doctor not wanting to sit down for an
interview with him
tell me why is it that as an unbiased
witness
you weren't willing to sit down with the
prosecution in this case with myself
with a defense attorney present recorded
etc and explain in advance
what you were going to be doing in this
case why do you really want me to
because you're a bully and i didn't want
to subject myself to that unpleasant
experience
typically i am called by the defense
uh and in a criminal case and
so
probably prosecutors are not that happy
uh when i come into the courtroom to
testify on behalf of the defense which i
think is true of you
oh i'm thrilled you're here
trust me
i would have driven you myself
i'll drive you home if you want all
right
so
prosecutor lewin then asked the doctor
about her work in the weinstein and bill
cosby cases and whether she determined
if the charges against the men were
untrue when she wouldn't answer lewin
objected
you know my request to the court is is
that if i ask her a yes or no question
and i don't think there's any issue that
she couldn't answer the question without
the extraneous information that she
answered the question that i asked and
that council can god is speaking it's
not a speech objection it's a it's a
request
you shouldn't be arguing these things in
front of the jury i thought i've warned
you about that before don't do it it is
appropriate don't do it stop
i'm just stop it's quiet i am going to
speak with the witness
let's bring back state attorney for palm
beach county florida dave ehrenberg and
correspondent angenette levy dave if you
were lewin uh i know you probably
wouldn't operate the same way where
would you cross-exam where would your
cross-examinations with durst start and
end if he takes the stand
well this guy is a triple murderer and
it's because he did kill those three
people he was found not guilty on uh the
second one
even though he dismembered the body
because they said it was self-defense
but he had motive he had means and they
want to portray him as a sick old man i
would just go into uh just ask him basic
questions about uh all the acts that
he's done and all the statements that he
has made that have contradicted each
other like for example he denied for
years that he wrote the infamous cadaver
note remember when susan berman's body
was found there was a note that was
mailed to police saying uh there's a
cadaver at this address and misspelled
beverly hills on the the envelope for
years durst denied that he wrote the
note because whoever wrote the note was
the one who discovered the body and was
involved with the murder now he
remembers that he actually wrote the
note uh it's uh it's just a pattern of
lies from a murderer and i hope that the
jury sees through that this is not the
sick old frail man that he wants you to
believe he's a cunning murderer who
deserves justice once and for all all
right so going for the inconsistencies
in his statements and jeanette what did
you think of the cross-examination of dr
loftus
you know i think brian that we all love
watching a good rough and tumble
cross-examination and some attorneys
really can get in there and
you know drive home a point and land a
punch
this was you know obviously classic
lewin very snarky we've seen this
through this entire trial that he gets
kind of rough with these witnesses
almost in um
you know the woman said she didn't want
to be bullied by him she didn't want to
sit down with him before trial so i you
know i think it's a little much but it's
what i expected yeah i'm wondering when
the jury is thinking about her excuse
for not sitting down with him do they
understand that sentiment or maybe
they're holding it against her at least
for me i think i would understand it to
some degree thank you both coming up on
law and crime daily inside the courtroom
for the trial of a man accused of
shooting a deputy at point blank plus
first-hand accounts from serve side
florida of the seconds and minutes after
the deadly condo collapse the video
capturing those desperate moments after
the break
[Music]
welcome back harrowing body cam footage
from police officers in surfside florida
captured the first moments as they
arrived at the condo collapse angela
levy is back with a new video and what's
next for the victims and their loved
ones
well brian i need to tell you right off
the top that this video is hard to watch
there was shock and confusion when
police arrived on the scene there is
body camera video from three surfside
officers that recorded every minute of
what they found
cries and screams for help come from
beneath the rubble the champlain towers
building collapsed the back part of the
building collapsed officers not yet
understanding the enormity of what had
happened
no dude the the buildings collapsed the
champlain towers south crashed to the
ground on june 24th around 1 25 a.m as
many residents slept one of the officers
searched the garage for survivors
[Applause]
the officer asking if people are hurt
the voices responding many so this is
the camera this is a stable here
others ran from their buildings hoping
to help like it's a check
right through the front of my property
another
the building's security guard thankful
to have gotten out fbc oh i see liar
wire just sparkle in the air so i say oh
god help me help me help him 98 people
killed in a matter of seconds the
officers who'd hoped to save lives step
back and begin to take in the loss
now a miami judge has approved an
initial 150 million dollars to go to the
victims and their families who suffered
losses of course that money will come
from the building's insurance policy and
any proceeds that come from the expected
sale of the property brian
thanks angela's bringing back state
attorney for palm beach county florida
dave ehrenberg now dave a minimum of 150
million dollars not including what will
likely be a class action suit could this
be the sign of a serious legal fault by
the condo
yeah and i think that there's still the
possibility of criminal charges although
i think it's unlikely
but you know there'll be a ton of civil
lawsuits there will be a class action
lawsuit that will be certified here
uh so yeah this is bad news for everyone
involved this is a horrific tragic uh
tragic loss of life and there will be a
financial hit to the condo association
uh but you know you can't get blood from
a stone at some point there's just not
going to be enough money and so i don't
know if they'll ever be fully
compensated from a financial standpoint
and from a criminal standpoint the only
crime that i think would be charged here
would be the crime of manslaughter by
copal negligence which requires
prosecutors to show a reckless disregard
of human life it's doing something or
failing to do something that the
defendant knew or should have known
would cause death or great bodily injury
it's like the person who shoots in the
air at a new year's eve party and kill
someone but based on what we know now i
don't think it rises that level until
the grand jury comes out with more
evidence and of course that grand jury
is reviewing uh this information as
we've been told and of course we'll give
you that update as we hear because there
could very well be as you're saying dave
potential criminal charges thank you for
your input
when we come back an accused cop killer
on trial what the defendant allegedly
said before the deadly shooting that
could blow up the defense's case next
[Music]
welcome back continuing coverage of the
tennessee trial of a man accused of
shooting a deputy and setting the
deputy's body on fire
stephen wiggins is on trial for
allegedly shooting dickinson county
sheriff's deputy sergeant daniel baker
stealing his squad car then lighting his
body on fire baker was killed back in
may 2018 while responding to a report of
a suspicious vehicle driven by the
defendant if convicted wiggins could
face the death penalty wiggins attorneys
admit he's the killer but say the
shooting wasn't premeditated but an
acquaintance of the defendant says he
heard wiggins make a shocking statement
not long before the shooting
did you observe a defendant
or a pistol in the defendant's lap yes
sir
and and did you tell the defendant to be
careful driving around dixon with a
pistol in his lap yes sir and what was
his response when you told him that
if anybody tries to arrest me i'll smoke
the defense has been extremely limited
in their cross-examinations but did ask
this witness if he only came forward
with this statement after he was
indicted on his own charges in a
separate case
would you disagree if agent niece said
it was november 23rd 2019. no because i
said i didn't remember okay
but you were indicted in august you
remember that right yeah you went to
court for that correct had several court
appearances for that correct right and
you knew you were facing a lot of time
for those charges
i had already been accepted into a
program before i ever done the statement
so
[Music]
i'd already
signed up for drug court and been
accepted into drug court when did you
sign up for that
there again i don't know the dates
but i was accepted into drug court
before i ever said anything about um
this case
which is why when you talk to the law
enforcement you repeatedly ask them did
you not what are they going to do to
help me since i'm giving them this
information i did ask yeah correct
but why did you need help if you already
had everything worked out
i don't know
dave could this alleged statement this
witness is telling us wiggins made mean
a premeditated act and does the saying
if in that statement uh change anything
i don't think his testimony makes a huge
difference because he has so much
evidence of premeditation the fact that
he lied about the car door being unable
to be opened forcing the sergeant to go
around the car and then he ambushed him
with a gun i mean that's plenty of
premeditation there
so i don't even think you you need this
guy but it does show an additional level
when he said yeah if anyone's smoke
stassing i'm going to smoke him so it's
just evidence on top of evidence i think
he'll be found guilty and guilty of
first-degree murder and then
i'm hoping he achieves the ultimate
punishment here because he deserves it
now dave i know that you're thinking
that this testimony doesn't really help
all that much but just a little question
about the defense's cross-examination
that we just saw does the timing of when
this witness came forward affect his
credibility in your eyes
you know it could i mean he definitely
has a motive to lie but you know these
kind of guys like wiggins they don't
hang around with choir boys you have
witnesses like this all the time who are
friends with people who would commit
such a horrific crime and so yeah you
know did he uh did he come forward
because he was going to get a deal it
was in his benefit sure it doesn't mean
he's lying and even if he wasn't telling
the truth there's still plenty of
evidence of premeditation remember when
it comes to premeditation you don't need
to have days of planning it just has to
be done like right before it's like the
example of someone who sees an aunt
walking around and you decide to step on
it that's enough premeditation so the
law is pretty generous for prosecutors
and i think that this witness will not
make a huge difference one way or the
other would absolutely agree the
defense's argument so far about
premeditation at least from my
understanding the state doesn't really
make sense like you said i don't want to
be that ant in your description but
stepping on the end is enough for
premeditation and i hear you when it
comes to the other witnesses his
statements i don't think are really
gonna go one way or the other uh this
statement i think helps the prosecution
but not doing much but at the very least
dave ehrenberg what i've learned so far
is i should get a choir boy of a friend
so i can maybe be a little better
position with people based on my
credibility but thank you very much for
joining us here at law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you